how's it going bros my name is barry pad
so you bros have been dying to tell me
that there's a new character in happy
wheels and I'm actually pretty curious
to check it out there's a new character
all right what the [ __ ] is that
oh come on I can do this that's a
helicopter really yeah
having a helicopter foot oh [ __ ] you
love the helicopter guy space deactivate
I'm cabbing I'm charging it it's coming
for it you're at it ha ha ha tricked you
[ __ ] boy yeah let's make a little
living like that what you don't have
fantage there's a tutorial I don't need
ok so I have a magnet I don't even know
how that works
ok I got it I got it
hahaha okay I have no [ __ ] clue what
happened there I like his shirt
[ __ ] swaggy I know I did not just say
that I said Maggie come here magnet what
happened I made it I made it hello
that's ah how are you
you have a beautiful ass Oh yogi oh god
what is happening if you so much pick
what does he do I have no control over
this somebody help me oh god that front
fit though good thing I wore my helmet
oh I can't oh I'm supposed to move the
wheelchair guy there we go go down
please go down when I say it that's
right [ __ ]
Oh God Oh God there we go hi pretty cool
it's pretty cool
ha ha ha SAP it's a lot let's go another
hi there sir just Venus will proclo lack
of knee I shall God why Johnny to defeat
mighty dry oh god oh god hello Howard
our magician I am on that quest okay
that one care La Paz Lucas white school
9 put VMA core oh it's curious that's
was what I hope that sign would say I
will never draw my sword oh I am drawing
my sword I am big on spawn of Satan yes
begun double spot okay well this is
getting old
oh god damn so many of you wow that was
a tough journey he's showing me his
boobs go away stupid demon
oh no more demons dead dead I hit them
in the balls and they are not happy
about it
those are some ugly tits oh wait it's a
map it's clear cool it cool it what I
don't even [ __ ] know I'll be on my
way I don't need on you of you tits that
was the best map I have ever played in
my life what what are you doing here
Timmy bro shot if you keep Timmy
you cut him a tip oh god Timmy I'm
Oh sir what just happened Demi you might
response a bit nevermind Timmy you begin
near a kid I god damn it what I tell you
Timmy Timmy you became someone's boobs
that's awesome Timmy you're the best
shot I ever had I got damn it now you
what I'm suck on your boobs man what get
more woman oh god damn I have hunt it's
okay I don't need a vest but to ride a
Vespa Vespa penetration Oh God
I don't understand his [ __ ] map
[ __ ] this map and let's do a blood run
for all panting my head if only you
didn't lose your balls - you piece of
[ __ ] why are we ready gratified God shot
gosh how'd you I don't care I really
don't I meant it - what's up do you come
here often but damn I run you're shunned
ah you look pretty hot
another torture chamber apparently these
needs to exist all right this fat
[ __ ] stole your cookie
she killed my cookie I mean she [ __ ]
wreck again same thing Lily
oh nice she cheated on you with another
guy she deserves okay well I guess fine
oh she seems to like it
a bawd a bawd shut up shut up just die
let's just pretend we're not hearing her
my god this is awkward as [ __ ] yeah shut
up
Santa Claus didn't give you a cool
present last year that's unfair
[ __ ] you se na try harder next time
[ __ ] triple shot you saw him kicking
your dog let him die slowly alright
I don't see how that's a slow death but
hey whatever I everyone so mean to me
what I must be like the worst person
ever
well that was surprisingly satisfying I
actually like that survived let's go
people rate fairly please dad I think
something stuck in my ass there's always
something stuck in your ass you piece of
[ __ ]
alright let's do it yeah oh hey that
baby
do you copy off dead you want to run
away but first dad what about me
let's run a far away from this base that
what about me ignore him it's just a
little pieces but Dad I'm tickling your
boss
oh you're sad you liked it mappers are
explosive baby not dad I'm an octopus
you're a [ __ ] alright alright please
don't kill my six month you have six
mobs really I'll do anything you then
straight baby straight baby thread rate
five if you want her to stay people are
apparently still falling for that [ __ ]
that that displays my [ __ ] mind
extreme
I have to agree
it's free fun
Santa's rage level punished too else for
mistakes they made no ranek bag no see
that's not mistakes that's just being
meme Santa no cars they are expensive
now I have to break them how's that work
so expensive no wrestling how dare you
wrestle ok I want to do more helicopter
runs maybe the children unharmed or you
will be don't tell me what to do [ __ ]
you oh no bad things are coming anything
but your katana babies okay we made it
yeah [ __ ] you baby ain't no baby
stopping when Prudie panties pop oh god
don't go down there don't go down eh
it's dangerous down there it's gonna
hurt my how to stuff it I like it the
hardest game to pass is wall rate [ __ ]
you chair race what the [ __ ] ready set
go
take me harm [ __ ]
[ __ ] this yeah I want that chair come on
baby let's go
what are you taking me there
pass the badass gap is Toby if you play
this the no rage quit please okay I want
it
well what just happen did my legs
teleport from the future yes I think
that's what happened look at my ass boy
it's [ __ ] beautiful
I got butt cheek implants for Christmas
what do you get you didn't give me any
present dad ha ha ha ha
best Christmas ever smack that ass if
you want to but I don't want to it could
be your gift oh okay then I smacked it
this is how you repay me but then I give
you my love love is forget got to see
what happens you may kill me but why
don't you ever kill my son kill him not
me thank you sir thank you best
Christmas ever
dad I'm not dead shut what was that oh
nothing nothing at that yeah
Oh God oh no oh no oh
small boy you came I came back to kill
you shut up touch god damn it there we
go did it Toby do you want to die I
exist to you know I have feelings
I got a Pollock hurry up I need a I need
a cushion nailed it
hope you bros enjoyed this video by boys
hearts they were like if you enjoyed
watching hits the sky come to earth
today and as always a breakfast - yeah